*Pouic*(jean-baptiste vous informe que vous allez avoir peur.)
Oh là là, mais j'vois des gens qui dorment beaucoup trop bien, ici, en ce moment.
Il faut qu'on leur fasse peur, un p'tit peu, là...
(Musique creepy en fond, beaucoup trop creepy) Les amis, comment allez-vous ?
Moi ça va !
J'ai découvert, pendant mes vacances,
l'existence d'une chaîne YouTube extrêmement creepy. ( on l'avait pas remarqué)
Et écoutez-moi bien,
j'ai regardé toutes les vidéos de cette chaîne,
(fin de la musique creepy et tant mieux) et putain, j'suis pas bien du tout.
Bien évidemment, comme tout le monde, quand je découvre une chaîne YouTube,
je commence par lire la description de cette dernière.
C'est faux ! *Rire*
Personne fait ça !
Mais moi je l'ai fait, là !
"Hey mon nom est Daisy Brown et wow je viens juste de comprendre que je peux faire mon propre compte YouTube !
J'pensais pas que les gens normaux pouvaient en faire un, j'croyais que c'était réservé aux célébrités qui avaient des
caméras qui coûtent chers"
Mais attends, elle vit dans un bunker ou quoi, là, Daisy Brown ?
"Merci de regarder mes vidéos et j'espère que vous voudrez bien être amis avec moi"
Wow wow wow, attends !
La chaîne a été créée le 27 juin 2017 ;
qui, à cette période, ne savait pas que tout le monde pouvait mettre des vidéos sur YouTube ?
Ça sent le traquenard, on est d'accord, alors qu'est-ce que j'ai fait après ça ?
J'suis allé voir la première vidéo de Daisy Brown.
C'est pas du tout ce que j'imaginais, bordel de merde.
(WTF ?)
(Squeezie choqué)
(bon, vous avez compris)
Ouais, on comprend mieux la description de sa chaîne YouTube, c'est clair.
Petit résumé : elle s'occupe d'un petit monstre qui s'appelle Alan
et qui se nourrit uniquement de sucre et d'eau.
Elle l'a découvert la première fois en allant dans sa cuisine,
il était là et il était beaucoup plus petit qu'actuellement, (il a pris du poil)
il a bien grandi entre temps.
Elle a d'abord eu très peur, puis son père lui a expliqué que tout allait bien,
qu'y avait rien de grave, rien de dangereux,
qu'il travaillait simplement sur la création d'une autre forme de vie
et qu'elle n'avait rien à craindre.
Mais mec, téma la gueule du truc !
Alors parlons de son père à Daisy,
c'est quoi ce bordel, là, dans cette famille ?
C'est un scientifique qui est plutôt intelligent
puisque c'est lui qui a créé Alan
et, vous l'aurez compris, il travaille dans la génétique et dans l'ADN.
On apprendra que Daisy est jamais allée à son laboratoire, à tel point qu'elle ne sait même pas où il est,
mais on sait que c'est là-bas que son père a créé Alan.
Après cette vidéo, Daisy met une vidéo d'elle au zoo, tout simplement.(musique orchestrale creepy)
Pas d'histoire de monstres, une vidéo parfaitement normale, que n'importe qui pourrait sortir.
On passe maintenant à la troisième vidéo, qui est...
horrible... (fin de la musique)
"ha" (" et égale à ce que dit alan)
"ha"  "ha"  "ha"
Il s'agit d'une vidéo dans laquelle, pendant qu'elle donne de l'eau sucrée à Alan, qu'elle le nourrit,
elle nous parle un petit peu de son père, donc elle donne les infos que je vous ai dit juste avant,
c'est un scientifique, etc.
Elle va ensuite donner un peu plus d'infos autour de Alan, et d'elle, et de son père et de sa maison,
parce que suite à la première vidéo, y a pas mal de gens qui se sont dits :
"mais purée il faut que tu en sache plus sur... ce p'tit monstre,
pour bien t'en occuper, pour pas le mettre en danger..."
*Rire nerveux*
Moi j'l'aurais buté, le monstre !
Des gens lui avaient alors conseillé d'aller dans le sous-sol de sa maison,
pour peut-être trouver des notes que son père aurait laissées,
pour en savoir un peu plus sur, bah, cette créature qu'a créé son père.
Wow wow wow, attends, mais c'est pas normal, là,
d'avoir une pièce comme ça, chez soi, fermée depuis qu'on a deux ans, là...
Ahhh, ouais c'est vrai, ça doit être pour ça. *Bruit de clignement d’œil*
Hein, c'est dangereux la moisissure...
Elle va alors terminer la vidéo avec un air un peu saoulé,
parce qu'y a pas mal de gens qui lui disent "eh il est où ton père, il est où ton père?"
Comme c'est le créateur d'Alan, forcément tout le monde a envie de le voir,
et elle dit qu'elle sait pas où il est, elle a l'air très blasée.
Attendez, attendez, attendez. Est-ce qu'on peut revenir un peu en arrière dans la vidéo ?
On a ce qu'elle ressent à travers les sous-titres de YouTube.
Ok... c'est un peu chelou, mais au moins on sait un peu mieux ce qu'elle ressent...
Mais c'est un peu chelou quand même !
On passe à la suite.
Alors, qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire comme vidéo sur YouTube
quand on s'occupe à plein temps d'un p'tit monstre ?
*Musique dramatique*
BAH ON LE MAQUILLE, BAH OUIIII *rire*
Elle va... le maquiller, putain de sa mère, pendant toute la vidéo.
Fard à paupières, rouge à lèvres...
Même pas au bon endroit puisque elle le met sur son VENTRE !
La vidéo suivante se passe sans Alan, puisqu'on voit Daisy dans son grenier
en train de chercher les fameuses notes de père,
qui pourraient lui en apprendre plus sur Alan et lui permettre de s'occuper mieux de lui.
Bon, pour sa cinquième vidéo, elle se creuse la tête, Daisy.
Elle se dit aujourd'hui on va faire un concept un peu plus poussé avec mon monstre...
*Musique dramatique*
Oh naaan...
Ok, encore une fois, on le rappelle, Daisy elle est dans son monde,
elle croit que tout le monde a la même vie qu'elle et que tout le monde a un monstre.
Elle s'étonne même que des gens aient jamais fait de vidéos make-up sur leurs monstres avant.
Elle est complètement dans sa bulle.
Dans cette vidéo, elle va donner plusieurs sucres à Alan,
mais à un moment donné, y a les fameux sous-titres dont je vous ai parlés qui reviennent.
Sauf que cette fois...
j'ai pas l'impression que ça décrive ce que ressent Daisy.
(musique glauque)
Et ça annonce un peu la couleur de ce qui va suivre.
Elle va ensuite refaire une vidéo où elle parle de ses plantes, c'est sa passion,
et, juste derrière, elle va faire une autre vidéo avec Alan.
La vidéo s'appelle "Alan grandit".
Et Daisy va expliquer que... y a des taches bleues qui commencent à apparaître sur son corps (l'adolescence !)
C'est dégueulasse, putain, mais c'est quoi ça ?
Deux semaines plus tard, nouvelle vidéo sur la chaîne de Daisy, qui s'appelle... (musique suspense creepy)
"Alan m'a arraché les cheveux".
*Voix aigüe* Mais, whaaaat ? Tu le nourris, tu lui donnes du sucre, il t'arrache les cheveux ?
J'espère que c'est pas pareil avec les bébés humains !
Sinon j'ferais jamais d'enfants, moi ! *Rire*
Une fois de plus, y a quelques sous-titres à la fin de cette vidéo,
qui nous montrent que Daisy est désespérée,
elle va dire : "j'peux pas y arriver seule", "s'il te plaît, reviens".
Elle parle probablement de son père, même si elle a jamais dit qu'il était plus là,
et on se doute que pour la suite elle va galérer sa mère encore plus.
Mais... c'qui... ça part en vrille.
On va ensuite avoir un mois et demi
sans nouvelles d'Alan et Daisy.
On espère qu'il l'a pas bouffée...
Et là, pouf ! Nouvelle vidéo
Il s'est fait quoi, bordel ?
Il a une plaie comme as dans la nuque, c'est pas arrivé par hasard ?!
Attends !
Alan !
Arrête maintenant !
Ça suffit !
Ici, on comprend clairement qu'Alan en a marre de la situation
qu'il a hâte d'être autonome, de pouvoir marcher,
de pouvoir... euh...
foutre
Daisy au vide-ordures.
Il se rassure en se disant que c'est pas grave ce qui lui arrive, parce qu'il grandit,
et on aimerait qu'il arrête un peu de grandir !
Parce que... il commence à avoir des pensées un peu machiavéliques, ce connard de monstre.
Apprès quelques vidéos qui servent un peu à rien,
Daisy met une vidéo en ligne qui fait... un peu froid dans le dos, on va pas se mentir, parce que...
Alan a grandi.
(creepy et glauque ces petits gémissements )
Putain, mais Daisy, mais tu le jettes et tu sautes dessus, à un moment ! *Bruit de destruction*
A quel moment quand on grandi on a une sorte de petit arbre d'une forêt maléfique sur la hanche, là ?
Et la bosse qu'il a sur la tête, on en parle ou pas ?
J'ai envie de taper dessus avec un marteau, mon gars...
Deux semaines plus tard, nouvelle vidéo,
et là on commence à se dire : "mais pourquoi t'as pas jeté ce monstre, bordel ?"
J'me répète, mais c'est HORRIBLE.
Daisy fait une vidéo où elle dessine, elle adore aussi le dessin, c'est l'une de ses passions,
et on entend Alan en fond qui fait beaucoup de bruit et c'est un peu chiant...
Au bout d'un moment, elle va le voir et elle le surprend avec des feuilles dans la bouche.
Alors elle s'inquiète pour sa santé
et pas pour sa vie à elle...
(bruit de mastication)
Elle lui retire le papier de la bouche et elle découvre sur le papier des dessins que elle, elle n'a jamais faits.
Il est capable de dessiner, le con ?
*Voix inquiète* C'est terminé, il va lui mettre des stylos dans les yeux et elle va mourir, c'est sûr. (SPOILER !)
Là on est clairement au summum de l'inquiétude
et pour couronner le tout, qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
Bah, Daisy elle décide de ne plus rien mettre en ligne pendant deux mois !
Mais merci Daisy, c'est une bonne idée, ça nous rassure, c'est gentil !
Deux mois plus tard, nouvelle vidéo intitulée :
"nous sommes de retour".
C'est quoi ça, elle a rapetissi, Daisy, ou quoi, là ?
*Musique angoissante*  ( et c'est qui-qui ?)
Naaan... me dîtes pas que l'autre est capable de tenir une... caméra...
*Fin de la musique angoissante*
(murmure sa mère)
Putain de merde !
Alan se met à faire des pranks sur YouTube comme Ibra !
Mais qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
Et surtout il est assez grand pour ramper et tenir la caméra, mec !
'Faut qu'il finisse sa croissance, un jour, parce que là ça va commencer à devenir dangereux en fait, l'affaire.
Après cette petite prank,
qui mérite un p'tit pouce bleu, on va pas se mentir !
la vidéo part en facecam, où Daisy explique pourquoi elle a fait une pause aussi longue sur YouTube, etc.
Et puis, à la fin de la vidéo,
c'est un rush de elle qui examine Alan pendant qu'il dort
et là, dans les sous-titres, les fameux sous-titres, c'est une sorte de flashback
d'une discussion entre son père et un inconnu, qu'on va appeler... "Michel",
et Michel explique à Curtis, le père de Daisy, que ce qu'il fait c'est très mal,
que ça le rend dingue qu'il s'en rende pas compte.
Curtis répond en insistant sur le fait qu'y a aucun mal à faire ce qu'il fait, qu'il a tout à fait le droit,
et la conversation va se terminer par Michel qui menace d'appeler les services sociaux
parce qu'il a peur que tout ça ait des conséquences très négatives sur la fille de Curtis, donc Daisy.
*Clape dans ses mains* On passe à un mois plus tard, on fait comme ça ?
Allez, on fait comme ça et on regarde tout de suite ce qu'elle a mis en ligne...
Daisy va faire une vidéo dans laquelle elle annonce avoir enfin trouvé les fameuses cassettes,
les notes de son père,
et j'avoue elles étaient bien cachées puisqu'elles étaient...
dans un petit placard de merde !
Putain !
Tu vas voir au grenier, t'as même pas regardé dans un petit placard de merde de ton salon !
J'commence à préférer Alan, là ! *Rire*
Daisy explique avoir trouvé des affaires de son père,
et plus particulièrement, le truc qui attire le plus l'attention de cette dernière, c'est une cassette
que son père a laissée, avec marqué au dos :
"Daisy, s'il te plaît écoute".
Daisy va alors mettre la cassette et là c'est hyper cool,
parce qu'on apprend beaucoup de choses sur son père et donc sur Alan et donc sur le fond de cette histoire,
parce que là on comprend toujours pas d'où vient Alan,
on comprend pas pourquoi c'est elle qui s'en occupe,
on comprend pas pourquoi on voit jamais son père,
on comprend que dalle !
Son père commence par direct lui dire qu'il va plus faire partie de sa vie
et que ça va être difficile pour elle de comprendre.
Il va ensuite s'excuser d'avoir travaillé pendant des années sur ces fameuses expériences,
d'avoir cherché à créer quelque chose qui lui apporte bonheur et épanouissement
alors qu'il avait Daisy juste à côté de lui et que ça aurait dû suffire, en fait, c'est sa fille.
Il va terminer son discours en disant que Rose serait fière de Daisy
et que plus Daisy grandit, plus elle lui ressemble.
On suppose donc que Rose est la mère de Daisy.
La fin de la vidéo est très glauque,
puisque Daisy va chercher un plaid et s'allonge par terre
et... elle va mettre en boucle le moment où son père lui dit qu'il l'aime.
On se doute à partir de là que ça fait un moment qu'elle n'a pas vu son père.
Une semaine après, Daisy poste la vidéo la plus mignonne de la chaîne,
puisqu'elle nous présente...
UN CHAT !
WOOOW ! Ça change de ce gros dégueu d'Alan !
*Musique dramatique*
Elle explique que le chat rodait dans le froid autour de chez elle, donc qu'elle l'a fait rentrer,
qu'elle a un collier sur lequel y a marqué son nom,
donc ce chat s'appelle Strawberry...
On espère qu'Alan aura pas le seum au point de....
Oh non.....
(oupsi)
Strawberry était très très vieille et est morte de vieillesse une semaine après ?
Ou est-ce qu'Alan l'a dézinguée ?!
Deux semaines plus tard, nouvelle vidéo de Daisy :
elle est en pétage de câble, en craquage psychologique total, allongée dans un amas de débris... (suicide direct)
Et, dans les fameux sous-titres,
on découvre un flashback d'une conversation entre Alan et Daisy,
dans lequel Alan dit que son père trouvait que Daisy était complètement diabolique,
que c'est elle qui a tué Rose, sa maman.
Grâce à ce moment-là, on peut comprendre toute l'histoire de Daisy et de Curtis, le père de Daisy :
Rose est probablement morte très peu de temps après avoir mis au monde Daisy ;
Curtis, ayant un chagrin immense, s'est mis en quête de... peut-être la ramener à la vie,
ou de créer quelque chose pour compenser le manque de Rose, sa femme,
et ça a donné... euh... Alan.
Un mois après son pétage de câble, nouvelle vidéo sur la chaîne de Daisy Brown.
Et le début nous montre direct que... c'est pas une vidéo comme les autres. (time code pour éviter de flipper de :11:37 jusqu'à  12:10)
Attends, mais pourquoi j'ai pas eu cette croissance, moi, de malade, là ?
Moi j'fais la même taille depuis que j'ai quatorze ans et lui sa tête elle a quadruplé de volume en un mois !
Ouais j'm'énerve, j'm'implique un peu trop dans cette vidéo... *Rire*
Il vient de la pousser dans le fameux sous-sol, (j'ai skip)
le sous-sol dans lequel elle n'est jamais allée, dans lequel on ne sait pas ce qu'il y a.
Nan nan... On n'a pas besoin d'un deuxième Alan, merde ! (et merde !)
J'en avais déjà un, ça suffisait !
Bon, "Alan 2",
qui s'appelle "Lithop", qui est un nom de plante,
explique à Daisy que c'est son père qui l'a fabriqué
en mêlant justement de l'ADN de lithop et de l'ADN humain.
Daisy va alors retirer le masque de Lithop...
elle aurait clairement pas dû. (non, elle n'aurait pas du)
(se barre)
Ah, c'est malsain ! Malsain... !
Bon, y a un peu du positif, on découvre qu'y a pas eu que Alan comme expérience,
et peut-être qu'elles n'ont pas toutes donné... une personne horrible comme Alan.(y'a pas de f""king positif)
Peut-être qu'y en a même qui vont pouvoir aider... euh...Daisy !
Ou alors, elle est dans la merde hein, clairement. (on va pas se mytho)
Dernière vidéo de la chaîne au moment où je fais cette vidéo,
elle a été mise en ligne il y a trois jours,
et j'attendais que il y ai justement cette vidéo-là,
parce qu'elle met fin à toute l'histoire.
Et c'est un peu triste, d'ailleurs, ce qui se passe.
La vidéo commence par Daisy qui fait ses affaires.
Elle a l'air d'avoir enfin compris qu'Alan est dangereux et qu'elle doit se barrer.
Elle a mis Lithop dans ses affaires, elle a l'air de vouloir emmener Lithop avec elle,
et tout se passe bien jusqu'à ce qu'elle prenne la cassette de son père pour l'emmener
et probablement écouter le passage où il lui dit qu'il l'aime,
parce qu'il lui reste plus que ça de son père.
(bang !)
*Camera qui tombe*
*Horrible bruit de craquement et de la tête qui implose sous le choc*
*Mélange de gémissement et de pleurs*
*Grande inspiration Daisy*
YEEEEEEES ! Putain ! Mais ça fait six mois, qu'on attend ça !
YES ! (champagne !!!!)
On sent qu'elle est un peu triste de l'avoir tué parce que c'était un peu la création de son père.
Mais d'un autre côté, elle a Lithop, qui est aussi une création de son père,
et qui a l'air un peu plus... bienveillant.(non.)
Alors elle va ensuite prendre ses affaires, y compris Lithop,
et partir au loin et on suppose que...
y'aura peut-être une saison 2, où c'est l'histoire de elle et Lithop ?
J'espère !
En tout cas, c'est la fin de cette vidéo, les amis !
J'espère qu'elle vous a plu, si c'est le cas n'hésitez pas à l'aimer !
Daisy Brown, la personne qui est derrière ce compte, elle a fait un travail de dingue.
C'est hyper malin d'avoir créé une sorte de personne qui est renfermée sur elle-même,
mais y'a un p'tit truc bizarre autour de son père...
Et c'est une nouvelle manière aussi de raconter ça, de faire genre qu'elle est YouTubeuse
et qu'elle a juste une vie pas très normale, mais elle elle croit que c'est normal...
J'sais pas, j'ai adoré cette idée-là, de transmettre une histoire à travers ça...
Voilà, tout ça pour vous dire que j'ai trouvé ça génial et je voulais absolument en parler
et décortiquer un peu toute cette histoire de Daisy Brown.
Hollywood, si vous pouvez lâcher des thunes à cette personne,
comme ça peut faire un truc cool, c'est bien hein !
Parce que là, quand tu vois les... les jambes de Alan quand il arrive à être debout
et c'est vraiment des jambes humaines peintes en bleu,
on comprend qu'y a eu quelques difficultés à financer le projet...
Mais franchement, ça rend le truc charmant justement, (CHARMANT ?!!)
c'est vraiment quelqu'un qui a voulu raconter un truc avec aucun moyen qui s'est chier, donc bravo !
Pleins de bisous à vous,
à bientôt dans une prochaine vidéo,
au revoir, bonne nuit !
Et attention...
j'ai cru voir un Alan sous votre lit.(fils de...)
*Rire d'enfant effrayant*
♫ Musique angoissante de "Psychose" ♫